he's actually doing up there I have no
idea but I could probably do that hi I'm
Ryan and from my experience what you
just saw right there is pretty much the
general line of thinking when it comes
to DJing electronic dance music in
general but rather than make outrageous
claims like I just did I thought why not
substantiate them by finding out what a
DJ actually does what makes a good DJ
and finally answering the burning
question is it really that easy
can anybody actually DJ even a silly
individual like myself probably not but
let's find out so I decided to come to a
rave and find out if anybody here could
tell me what a DJ actually does and what
makes a DJ good obviously I'm at the
right place right no all right let's
find out you guys are EDM experts what
does a DJ actually do on stage they push
buttons pick songs are gonna make people
dance and just hit play whatever let's
say hypothetically I train with a DJ
coach for a week do you think I could
deliver a solid set in one week yes you
yeah me no okay cool it can happen right
so I would say photo confidence from the
second banana that's good nice look at
his face he could do it so there was my
challenge
one week to figure out how to DJ before
a real live crab but lucky for me I
managed to get the headline DJ's to sit
down with me before they went onstage
what are you doing when you're on stage
you have two trucks different tempo you
pitch the one so they're basically the
same tempo and then try to make a
transitional between them that sounds
good that's the technical part of really
technical but not a spiritual part I
would say like having fun a lot of
people think like you should give the
crowd what they want you should always
give them what they didn't know that
they wanted that was very very just
Confucius like but that's what it is is
that factor of like surprise just feel
out the rhythm yeah and it's like take
them for a ride I've been told that I
have the rhythm of a dead body by my
parents please a dead body teach your
dead body there you go yeah
do you think anybody could DJ getting
the technical just like mix lease track
who like this that's I always say that's
fairly easy but getting to your next
step where you can just purely relax
don't think at all just have fun that's
another step and I have a week to get to
that point so also where to so we're
kind of shootings yeah from the
technical point of view you definitely
can learn to DJ in a week if you're
musical to start with you can do this
thank you thank you I don't think I can
but like the more people tell me that
you can okay
after that confidence boost from Dada
life I was ready to start training so I
met what my DJ coach say my name at his
house
yeah track a and track B your mixer
allows you to be match or blend the two
if you're not already and you just saw a
track on it's gonna sound like a train
wreck which is basically ting if that
happens to me on stage will you still
admit that you coached me or will you
probably just bow your head and shame
how does look away at what point did I
get to purple nurple the little oh wait
let me put it that a little bit on this
CD J we have kick out the epic which is
originally at 128 beats per minute and
we have a heart rap song that's
originally had 150 beats per minute
so you can hear this track coming
you hear that that's this right
now ready to kill this right
now I can bring the BPM of this truck
back up to 150 beats per minute now I'm
warning you this is a pretty hard you
know it's all it's hard trapped it's
intense does it sound I'm working on
it's a sound I've made and it's you know
it's crazy
add some afoot good a trout yeah so I
got it slightly aroused right there I'm
not gonna lie when you did that mix you
Kitana the [ __ ] out of that like their
way opposite you know BPM ranges and you
got to figure out how to bring them in
in front of an audience and make it
sound good you know
hey introduce our celebrity DJ judges
say my name dada life
let's go ahead and kill this thing Oh
buzz he's very on Ryan vegara aka DJ
dead body
it's
all right that's pretty good it's pretty
good transition master let's hear it
from say my name yo Ryan
you killed it bro I saw the headphone
core it's just like pop out and you're
just like what's going on but you
recovered quickly and you made it just
in time for that transition I'm giving
you a tin for that dude like ten out of
ten solid alright now we're gonna hear
from dada life okay good work for one
week but your moves kind of look like
DJs in a movie they feel kind of forced
overall we're really happy good work
being a DJ but don't quit your day job
wicked ever happy I end right there
anyways what makes a good DJ hard work
in the studio and being able to live in
the moment
can anybody DJ I guess so granted I had
a lot of help and I didn't make any of
the songs I just used I guess what I'm
trying to say is that I have a lot more
respect for DJs in general and unless
you want to take it seriously and put
the time in don't plan on DJ anytime
soon and that's a fact
you